okay welcome to clojurescript
it's not just a language my name is
castelnou Olsen I work for called marker
which is a consultancy here in town and
I'm going to be talking to you today
about closure script and as the title
indicates this talk will primarily be
about - not the main language so much
but more the tooling around the language
so I've been working with web
development for 15 years I worked
extensively with JavaScript and the
various libraries and frameworks that
popped up along the way and a few years
ago I started working with closure
script and as of now I'm not jumped
yet
so this is so far in my career been the
definitely the most fun and productive
way I've found to develop web
applications and while the language is
obviously a part of that it really is a
tooling that's been built up around by
the community that seals the deal and
the idea of this talk is to try to sell
you some of my enthusiasm for that
tooling by showing you how it works
so but before we get to the demos we
have to talk a little bit about language
- you guys know what it's about
so clojurescript is a functional
language that compiles to JavaScript and
runs in the browser it is also a lisp
and Lisp is a family of languages like
they first emerged in the 1950s and
lisps have a certain some prejudice
against them with parentheses and so on
and I'll get back to that in a moment
but the main characteristics of the
closure script language is like I said
it's a functional language and it has a
suite of immutable data structures and
it has a huge standard library for
working with immutable data structures
and most of that affords you lacy
evaluation as well so I'll just I'm
going to show you just a few examples to
get you started so let's say you have a
list of numbers so that list being
immutable means that whenever I perform
an operation like adding something to
the list or splitting it into or
whatever
that operation will always create a new
collection so if we can see here can you
read the text oh it's too far to the
left
tell me okay is that good even better
okay so why thank you can see I have a
collection called numbers and then I
added the number four and I have a new
collection and hopefully my existing
collection should still be the same and
it is because it's immutable so you can
never really change in line values you
don't have mutable state or you do have
a mutable state but you have specific
constructs to work with mutable state
including scripts so this is this
feature is to prime enabler of many of
the other cool things that I'll show you
eventually another example would be to
create a sequence of a lot of numbers
like a million numbers like that and
then I'll create a function that can
square a number and just for demo
purposes we're going to print which
number is being squared and then we're
squaring that number this is my function
and now I'm going to create some squared
numbers by mapping over my 1 million
numbers with this square function and
here's the trick this is now being
calculated blatantly so if I ask for the
first first four numbers of this
collection we will see that a squared
map squared numbers ah sorry we'll try
it once more
now if I ask for the first four numbers
I'll get back 0 1 4 9 and then it prints
out square 1 0 2 3 so it's actually just
performing the map on the items that we
do actually need it's not doing it a
million times and if I do that once more
we'll see that it's not going to
recompute the values at all because
they're immutable so there's no point in
reevaluating the function so that's
the core features that I'll focus on for
now we're also have to talk a little bit
about parentheses because there's this
myth that lisps have just huge amounts
of parentheses and for a clue to scripts
sake it's partly true but it's also
partly myth and in the cases where it is
true it's actually an advantage and I'll
show you some examples so the first
thing that people notice is that when
you have JavaScript code looks like this
you call a function if you do the same
function call in closure script it's
going to look like this so the
parentheses is all wacky placed on on
the left side and this confuses people
but this doesn't really add parentheses
right it just puts it in a weird place
another case where closure script
usually does have more parentheses is in
the case of arithmetic expressions so in
order for you to understand this
expression the way that it's going to be
evaluated you have to know more than
what it says on the paper because there
are proceedings rules for operators
right so you have to know which
operators being applied first so this
could turn out as 11 or 15 depends on
how the engine understands your
expression enclosure script you would
just add parentheses to avoid this
problem at all so in this case there are
more parentheses but it's an advantage
because it's become more explicit and
closer Script doesn't have operator
proceedings rules at all so it's just
less stuff for you to know about which
in my book is a good thing okay here's a
JavaScript function and I'll show you
the closure script equivalent and we'll
compare them side-by-side so which has
the most parentheses it turns out that
they both have the same amount of
parentheses it's just that closure
script has more of the wrong kind and
JavaScript has more of the squiggly kind
but the more interesting aspect of this
comparison is that the closure script
version does not really have a lot of
syntax so in JavaScript you have syntax
to create a function you have syntax to
do flow control
there's syntax to return values in
closure script you have basically none
of that so
we're gonna investigate the data types
including script to understand why that
is okay so this is going to be a really
quick race through a bunch of data
structures including script I'm not
intending for you guys to understand the
language very deeply at this point it's
just trying to make a point about the
syntax of the language so cluttered has
strengths strings are JavaScript
strengths you can call JavaScript
methods on them there's there's no layer
in between
Clojure script also has keywords which
are kind of like strengths you would use
them in cases where you want to address
things so as keys and maps or objects
stuff like that they can also have
namespaces as you see in the example
here we have numbers they are JavaScript
numbers and then we have symbols which
in JavaScript you probably know them as
just variable names or function names
and that's also the role that they
usually play enclosure script but you
can also process them as data which is
important and then you have lists so
because lists are immutable like any
other piece of data including script
they also have value semantics so in
JavaScript you can compare string to
another string and they will be the same
if they have the same content but if you
take two arrays that are the different
object instances they would not compare
the same enclosure script they will they
have value semantics because of
immutability and this applies to all of
the data structures including scripts so
vectors are just a slightly different
kind of list which would be the one that
you would use the most also has value
semantics and then we have maps maps are
you'll use maps including script just
like you use an object in JavaScript and
if you're the kind of developer that
likes to discuss where to put the commas
at the beginning or at the end you will
love closure script because you can have
as many comments as you want closure
script treats commas is whitespace so
you can leave them out or you can
include them in if that helps you in
most cases maps and closure script will
use keywords as keys so the structure
will look like this
again you have value semantics so if you
have two different maps with the same
content they will compare true then we
have assets which are lists of unique
things okay cool let's get back to our
function here so again we're looking at
a function and now that we've quickly
seen all the data that clutter Script
supports we can understand this piece of
code and the different framing because
the parentheses those are the syntax
literal for lists the square bracket
here is the syntax literal for vectors
this here is a map so in fact closure
script data is closure script code and
floater script code is closure script
data so there's no particular syntax to
the language other than that of its data
structures and this is a really elegant
simplicity to it which means that you're
always working with data and when you
evaluate data is code then the list form
will be a function call so in this case
defin defines a function included script
but it's really just a special kind of
function call the same with if if this
really just a function call and this is
a gives Lisp it's peculiar look and
gives the rise to the parentheses myth
but really it looks this way because
it's uniquely simple and elegant at its
core so that's cool I'm gonna talk more
about why it's good for the code to be
data a little bit later in the
presentation okay
now I'm gonna show you the first tool
which is fig wheel which is a tool
that's developed for instant feedback as
you develop code and to do this I have
created a stupid little app to show you
how it works so let me just resize my
and we know okay so it's just the app
that it shows animal faces and there's a
small icon that you can click and you
can choose to remove it or not okay so I
click this button it didn't really work
so
there's a bug in a bug in the program so
we're gonna fix the bug in the program
so usually when you work with web
applications you would then go to your
code find the bug I'm not gonna tell you
all the details about this code I'm just
gonna tell that here it says dilute it
should have said delete so I fixed that
and then what you do you go back to the
browser reload your app and then now you
have to retrace your steps click all the
buttons and then figure yes okay I sold
the bug but this is kind of tedious
right because the more complex your
application becomes the harder it will
be for you to recreate the exact state
that showed you the bug in the first
place and and you were going to be
clicking and scrolling and doing these
things over and over again and you lose
your flow right hopefully this is a
familiar situation for you so now I want
to close this pop-up here by clicking
somewhere and that doesn't work either
so now I can do the same thing again or
we can try to do something better so the
reason why the code got updated in the
first place is because I'm already
running fig wheel which is a library but
I'm not running it in its power mode so
let's fix that I'll ask it to include a
repple which is a read eval print loop
and I'll ask you to all auto load my
code and then I have to do something
which takes a little bit of time
mmm okay reloads confit
so now figure well it's going to dump
all the compiled code and compile
everything from scratch and then I have
two builds running so this is going to
take a little bit of time but once it's
done we're not gonna have to wait for
pretty much anything at all I'll just
find the file while over wedding so this
takes about 20 seconds per built ish
cool okay so the idea now is that we're
going to add two to this section of the
code this is the data that's being added
for rendering when you're watching the
details so we want to add a cancel
action into this so now I'm going to
reload the app manually for one last
time and now I click here here now and
now I want this to work clicking here
should close this thing so I can then go
in here and add a cancel action again
the details of this isn't really all
that important pictures basically I'm
going to remove the show details flag
from this particular picture so when I
do this figure well is hopefully going
to recompile my code and it should have
reloaded the browser which it didn't so
that's interesting okay so now it works
something's amiss okay
now you can see that every time I save
the file the browser gets updated and
it's reloaded for me so this is one step
better now I don't have to press the
reload button anymore but I still lose
my context so if I go in here click this
one click here and then change my code
then figueira is going to reload the
browser and I still lost the current
state of my application so this is not
really a much of an improvement at this
point in order to fix that less that my
code has to be reloadable which means
that when closure script or yeah the
process
this file and places it into the browser
again it cannot override pre-existing
global state because if it does then I
lose the state of the application and
I'm back to scratch so clojurescript
makes it really easy to solve this
problem because it has immutable data
and it has specific tooling to manage
mutable State which is the core of the
problem and in the case of this
application
I have only one piece of immutable state
which is defined here
it's called store at this line and then
every time this file is being updated
it's being loaded into the browser and
it's just recreating the initial state
if I change the DEF to a Def once that's
no longer going to happen that's going
to create the state one time I can
manipulate it over time and then when
the code is reloaded it's not going to
override that global variable so the
other piece of the puzzle that makes
this work is that this is being rendered
by by react and react has a diff mode
for updating the UI you give it some
data it performs a diff with the
previous version and it updates the Dom
it it doesn't have to be react but that
model of updating your UI certainly does
help so with this in place I can now go
and change let's say I can go in here
look at the details then find a details
component and add some text to it just
to see if it pops up I save that file
and now the text just pops up in the
current state of the application and
this is very very useful when you're
developing complex applications you have
lots of drop-down menus and you can
click and drag and scroll all the places
you never lose your place so this is
very cool for for the code obviously
it's also used for for for CSS you can
see that many of my components are using
inline Styles here but some are not so
the if you can see the I in the corner
of the image here if I wanted to change
that I could find the CSS file that this
application uses
and then there's a button down here so I
want to add transition to the button for
the background give it a little bit of a
sushi effect and then on hover I'll
change the background to black just save
it and then when I hover now it has a
nice effect art or not because I'm not a
designer but it has an effect anyway so
yeah you never need to lose your place
again you could just keep your context
very very very useful this is of course
possible in other languages as well but
the immutable data surprise you with
makes this really simple to do okay but
maybe this is just one browser let's say
that I'll add a phone into the picture
and oh now I can see that the pictures
are actually too wide to fit on the
iPhone so if I get into my core file
there should be okay so here says that
the width should be 500 pixels actually
that's too wide for an iPhone so I want
to set max width instead there we go I
say that and then things should look
fine in the iPhone as well cool and then
my app works great here as well and yes
you can use the console to do fix that
the status which tells you something
about the status of your system so now I
have two connections to the dev build
which is the iPhone and the Chrome and
then I have a test connection here which
I'll show you in a minute so if you see
my browser there on the tab to the left
here there's a green square and that is
the tab that fig wheel is also running
which is running tests this is really
tiny but it's not really all that
important so this is not very useful
test output but the favicon on the top
here is quite useful so let's say that I
unfixed my bug from before then this tab
is going to turn red so I just keep this
up just for a small visual clue of what
the state of my tests are in
for actual test feedback and and for CI
sirs and whatnot you can run the test in
in a console like you would in other
languages so the details again not all
that important but the visual clue here
is really nice there's one more feature
which is quite useful so sometimes not
all the time but occasionally I make
mistakes when I write my code and
perhaps I misspelled a variable name
like this and if I do that the codes not
going to work correctly so figure will
tells me that with really tiny font it
says that it point out the exact place
where there was a warning and then it
does one more thing and that is that it
does not reload the code because really
in reloading the code at this point
would break the application so instead
of just prompts me that there's a
there's a problem here you should fix it
and when you fix it I'm gonna reload the
code for you same thing happened happens
if you have a compilation error which
you can do if you've have unbalanced
expressions or whatever same thing is
just that the Box gets ominously read
yeah the boxes ominously read and the
error message will sometimes be less
helpful yes cool so that is the basics
of fig wheel yeah you can see that the
info that I got up earlier is still up
and yeah very very useful I'm gonna show
you more figure well a little bit later
okay so when you have a compile to
JavaScript language like closure script
is then you don't really want to
recreate the entire world in its image
you like the JavaScript community has
vast amounts of tooling and libraries
and all kinds of stuff and having to
recreate it all included scripts would
be quite a loss so closure scrip
provides excellent Interop with the
JavaScript runtime and
also the library ecosystem around it so
just a few examples I'm gonna fix my
window again
okay so the slash is closer scripts way
of denoting namespaces and the jeaious
namespace gives you access to all the
JavaScript Global's so jeaious slash
window is the window object if you want
to access properties on JavaScript
objects you can do that while this
syntax doc - location this is the window
location or you can use the more
familiar look of this so if I evaluate
this it shows me the location yeah
getting properties nice and easy
if you want to call methods on
JavaScript objects which you do
sometimes you do like this this mimics
what Lisp usually looks like do you have
the function first so in the case of
object methods you have the function
name and then the object and then you
have other parameters if you need them
so here's an example of slicing string
and this is really this is just a
different way of writing JavaScript
right so this is useful when you're
using the browser API or if you're using
libraries like d3 that would be a bit of
a chore to rewrite the entire thing in
including script and you can just use
those things and there's excellent
syntax support for doing so you can even
use no modules so in your compiler
configure configuration you can now say
installed apps true and then you can
list NPM depths that you need for your
application in case you need to
interrupt with for instance d3 or other
JavaScript libraries so you want to use
and then you when you use the
clojurescript build tool it's gonna
install the npm that dependencies in the
background for you and create a package
to taste and then manage that for you
and then in your namespaces I can
require close
set from the standard library floated up
string from the stand of the library and
this library which actually comes from
knowled modules so this is a fairly
recent addition to the closure script
compiler but it has been really really
useful you can even do like this and
import individual files from from the
modules that you pull in like you would
require for this you have used
JavaScript before I'm just assuming that
you have at least passing the little
script otherwise this makes no sense
okay let's revisit those parentheses I'm
gonna get back to one more example of
interactive development but first we've
got a take a look at the parentheses so
parroted is an editing mode that
originally came with Emacs
but is now available for IntelliJ and a
bunch of other editors and it's a
different way of editing code than
you're used to so instead of
destructively changing the the source
code of your program character by
character parroted relies on the fact
that Lisp code is data and then it
allows you to manipulate those data
structurally instead of just wiping our
characters nilly willy and this is it's
quite different way of writing code than
you're probably used to so in the
beginning it's really painful and when
you learn how to use how to use it then
going back to the old way is extremely
painful so I'm going to show you how it
works
but first we have to see a famous quote
about parodied so my friend manga nurse
fan once came into the IRC channel for
closure and he said that I
I've tried pirated it's not really for
me and the response that he got was if
you think parodies is not for you then
you need to become the kind of person
pirated it's for and this is this is
very true initially you're going to
think that this is not for me but you
just have to change the definition of me
and it's going to fit perfectly so
excellent
okay very basically with parody it makes
sure that things that need to stay
balanced are balanced so in a clue to
script program a single single double
quote has no meaning so whenever you
insert a double quote it inserts
two for you so you can write a string if
you want a double call inside your
string you can get one and it's going to
get escaped if you try to delete the
final back double coil it's not gonna
let you because that would screw your
program so you can go all the way back
here and when the strings empty you can
remove the whole thing perfect this will
be extremely annoying in the beginning
but when your user is very very useful
so everything that comes in pairs get
inserted in pairs so lists there there's
no reason at all to have a single left
parenthesis in a closure script program
so you'll always want to have two of
them with a vector or the same thing and
yeah squiggly brackets and all those
things get paired up very nicely so then
we have three other functions call kill
slurp and barf
so Emacs has interesting terminology
kill in Emacs is its if that's the name
they gave to just removing text that's
called kill it's very aggressive so for
instance if I have a long line here I
can hit control K to kill to end of line
just removes the rest of the line when
you do this inside a lisp expression
like let's say that this function no
longer needs arguments and I hit ctrl K
here it's going to remove the rest of
the expression it's inside of so it has
knowledge about the structure wherein
the code lives and this is perfect
because doing this would not be useful
for me because now I have an unbalanced
program it won't even compile so there's
no need for my editor to support that
well it can because I can select text
and cut it but that would be making
things hard for
yourself similarly it has a function
called barf so I have a vector here with
five characters in it let's say I'd only
you the last one anymore
I can barf it out I'll say go and then I
can kill these two and I can slurp them
back in and now I remove the two first
arguments this is this example is quite
contrived I'll write some code later and
you can see me using it in action but
one relevant example of this would be
let's say you have something printing to
the screen hello world and then I figure
out ah I only want to print this if it's
midnight so I'm gonna add it if they
bent that looks like this and then I can
slurp the expression right in and this
allows you to like I said manipulate the
structure of your code as pieces of data
instead of just swiping and placing and
you'll also notice that there's no need
for me to manually re indent or anything
like that it just keeps it positioned
exactly what it needs to go
it's very good
okay next function is called rate so
here I have an if and the if can only
have two forms in it the first will be
the the if clause and the second will be
the then Clause or else Clause now I
have two expressions that I want to run
in my if Clause so I put it in a do and
the dude simply allows me to group
multiple expressions as one so let's say
that I figure out that I don't really
want to print here anymore so now I only
have one expression inside to do and
then I don't really need to do so then I
can erase this expression and it will
take the place of its parent expression
so similar I could have figured out just
here that I don't want to print anymore
so I'll just have one expression so I'll
just raise this one out and it takes the
place of its parent expression quite
useful here's a similar one race is
perfect for lifting one expression to
one level up if you want to list both of
these expressions up then you have to
use this way layer name function here
not gonna try to pronounce it but let's
say that I figure out that I don't want
to have my conditional anymore
everyone's gonna eat ants from now so
I'm gonna start by racing to do to take
place of the if and then inside the
function body I don't need to do so now
I can do
splice sex killing backwards to remove
it and then I'm left with only these two
expressions so it looks strange when
it's new but I promise you when you when
it's in your fingers manually editing
codes character by character feels
extremely clumsy this is Emacs yes
but the same editing mode is also
available for vim and IntelliJ and most
other popular editors use it as an atom
to install yes final example here I have
an if an inside the if is a left so
though that defines the local variable
settings and it turns out that this
expression is being used twice so it
would be cool to move the if inside the
let so I could use the variable instead
of looking up the value twice and to do
this I can use convolute s expression
which is the very aptly named which does
this so it switches the place of the let
and the if and it also in mind the
variable that I have here like from
before it was this is a map lookup and
then I convoluted it and boom it's now
using the variables this one I don't get
to use as often as I would like but
whenever I see enough possibility to use
this feature I feel like a god it's a
it's highly recommended so that is
parotid it looks a little bit strange
but it plays in with language very very
nicely and it really feels like power
editing one thing I did not show you is
that you can also use para to navigate
your code so I can go to the end of the
expression to the beginning of this
expression I can go down into the
expression and move in this level
and down one more time and you have this
really neat way of navigating the
structure of your code so you don't have
to use your arrow keys as much to flick
around or god forbid the mouse to select
stuff okay back to our face applications
I'm gonna drag my window so when we
introduce figure wheel into this
application I was able to keep the state
and and work on local permutations of
the application but there are some kinds
of feedback that are hard to it some
kind of features that are hard to
iterate on even with that kind of
feedback and example would be like if I
remove this monkey you see there's a
really quick animation if I wanted to
study like the details of that animation
and and and tweak it then figgle doesn't
really help me with that because the
animations still passes along in 250
milliseconds and my brains not able to
work that quickly so we're going to look
at a another tool or actually a
companion tool called dev cards which
solves this problem yes mmm
so I will get back to my okay so we're
going to start another builds called dev
cards
and then I'm going to open a new tab
called
cards and again the initial compile when
you start a new bill takes a little bit
of time but the idea behind this tool is
to take a component if you have like a
react component or any component
technology and then you can display all
the different permutations of the
component on a single page so in this
app I have a a button that you saw
before I'm just gonna find the code
that's colors here is my button so now I
want to display the button on a page of
its own so I can just look at the
intricacies of the button if you will so
to render the button I simply call the
button component and pass in the text
click me and to render this in dev cards
I'm going to call def card and I call it
basic button slurp it in and then I say
the file gets compiled and I can go in
here so now I have this is a dev card
for the button component it lists one
button excellent you can add some
documentation here the button is a
clickable UI component very useful and
then you can also include markup in here
so you can use this as a way of
documenting your UI components living
documentation you can look this over yes
it has quotes
okay so yeah so you can use this like
living documentation of your components
and then you can add more cards like
this for the same component so now I'll
call a create a colored button so it
takes a color like so and then when we
have the color button I can have a
disabled button disabled question mark
true and I could just lay out all the
permutations of the single component on
one page and this increases my bandwidth
of feedback right you can see multiple
states at once red button so here we go
okay this component though is not very
exciting because it doesn't really have
a lot of interesting states but here you
can see let's try to develop a little
bit more interesting component that we
can view in this view so I'll try to
create a progress bar so here I have a
sing a simple dev card that it has a
progress bar with progress zero and then
I'll add another one with which have
some percent 25 for instance and then
we're going to have to actually create
the component so it's just two styles
for now our two spans for now let's add
some styles here we'll make it
position:relative it'll make it
background dark like that height should
be maybe 8 pixels I can save it under
way to see what it looks like right now
it doesn't look very nice let's add some
text back here hello hey yeah okay width
should be probably a hundred percent for
this one or actually let's make it
display:block and you you have the same
interactive feedback that would feed fig
wheel it's still figure with running but
in a different view of the application
ok cool
border-radius we'll add a couple more
features this and then we'll take a look
at this one we'll have background
something light to overlay it
then we'll be absolutely positioned one
pixel from the top one pixel from the
left the height will be four and then
finally the width will be the progress
and then with the percent marker after
it let's see what that looks like okay
it's - it's not tall off and let's just
make a little bit bigger so you guys can
see so I'll make it 18 and 16 a huge
progress bars okay I can see there's
some glitch over in the edge here
because I'm missing the border radius
yeah anyway my point here really is just
to show you that what this kind of
instant feedback allows us to do without
code it's very useful now I'm gonna do
one more thing with this component and
that is I would like for this to
progress like smoothly if I tell it to
increase the progress I wanted to move
smoothly along so to do that we're gonna
have a transition on I guess this
component on the width and then in order
to watch that live I need the progress
to change so def cards has a feature for
this so we'll create a time card
interactive progress bar and then if you
pass in a function then that card is
going to create a piece of mutable state
and pass it to you so I can render the
progress bar using that data and then I
have to do something where to it and
then you can provide some initial data
progress 0 let's just make sure it works
okay so I have an empty progress bar and
now I need to provide some way to
increase this value and we can do that
with just some elements here this is
just react HTML virtual Dom elements
I'll create an a that has an on-click
there will be a function and that is
going to do swap which is how you update
mutable state in
in this particular case and then we're
going to do update progress P and then
if the progress is 100 we're going to go
back down to zero otherwise we'll just
increase the progress with five cool
then we need some text for the button
and going fast now because the details
are not all that important increase
progress and then I know that we're
gonna need to have some margins okay now
we should get a button and when I click
it it's going to huh so now I can really
contemplate the details of my wonderful
animation but you know for some kinds of
components being able to just control
control it very finely like this is very
useful and I can see that when it
reaches 100 it actually goes to pixels
over the edge there so that's an inch
case I would have to figure out like you
wouldn't be able to catch this when it
just switches switches on the screen so
because closure screen has such
fantastic tools to manage mutable state
cool deaf cars can do one more thing for
you so we can do inspect data here and
then when we do that it's going to tell
me the current state of the so if you
have like this could be a huge map with
lots of data for a complex component and
it will tell you the entire state of the
other component what we can also do is
to ask you to add some history and then
when I hit this button this other line
shows up here and I can step back to the
previous version but this was really
interesting okay one forward and then
get back to the current version so this
is a very very useful tool to develop
like individual components like this and
just to drive home that point I'm gonna
show you one for my daily work which is
on this this is a mobile application for
home automation stuff so this is my
living room you have some components
here you can set the temperature you can
create a schedule for when the
temperature should do what and then this
entire application is built from
individual components that we have these
kinds of cards for so the buttons for
instance like these are all our buttons
some of them have spinners on them blah
blah blah
we had the components that I showed you
the resizable areas are here we can just
try them out
this shows the coloring of the
temperature and you can just I worked on
this today it's not done yet
yes and also in this application very
cool I did not I did not make the thing
that I'm going to show you now but uh
whenever you go between patrons has this
really nice mobile application swooshy
effect and we have cards for that as
well so let's go back here and page
stack so here here's the app with one
page rendered and then when you click to
have a new page added it's getting
rendered on the outside and then it's
slides over into the frame while the old
page slides just a little bit out which
gives this really cool skeuomorphic
effect and in this case I can actually
step through the animation so this is
what happens to the entire page when you
navigate in the app and I think
developing a feature like that without
something like this is very frustrating
to say the least of it and this tool is
not very advanced but it relies on the
environment that a closure script
creates with its focus on the immutable
data and this library that I'm using
that is using react under the hood which
is not allowing me to use component
local States which would make it harder
to make this work so I have one final
example for you which is an old game
that I did some time ago this is just a
I'm browser-based minesweeper that I
wrote including script so with fig wheel
you also get a repple and a replica like
I said read eval print loop and this is
connected to the browser so we can see
that by I can interrupt with JavaScript
and say console.log hello and then it
gets compiled since the browser and it
prints hello in the console here which
is okay but it's also connected to the
actual state of the application so if I
get into the namespace sweeper UI I
think it's going to switch into that
namespace and then I can look at app
date I hope but that's not what it's
called at all
it's called app state I guess no that
was not good let's see if we can find
the file and then we'll figure it out
it's called app data here mm-hm
okay
the ref app data come on okay here we go
so this is the entire data structure
that's being rendered right now and to
the bottom you can see it says dead true
because I screwed up a hit and hit the
bomb in my game so this namespace also
has a function to undo that move even
though there's no UI for yet so I can
even call that function and I can
control the state of the application
from the repple and this is just a
hugely powerful because now I can I can
in my editor interface with the state of
the running application in the browser I
can see the current state of the data I
can manipulate the current state of the
data and I can run individual functions
I can develop half a function inject it
into the game click around and go back
and forth and this level of
interactivity I've never found in any
other development environment and it's
it's really really awesome and I really
suggest you check it out even though the
language has a few parentheses and looks
a little bit strange so that was really
what I had there's a bunch of other cool
things that I don't have time to show
you today I'll just mention them in
passing the community is very very good
for a closure script if you count like
stars from github and questions on Stack
Overflow and the other useless kinds of
metrics it's not as big as other
communities but it's very positive if
you they have a slack channel everyone
gets I have their beginner questions
answered people are very friendly
helpful and very important for me is I
get older I get more and more tired of
having to patch libraries and fix like
deprecation warnings and crap like that
and the closure script community has
been very good at just keeping
backwards-compatibility
a main objective so I can find like this
minesweeper application I wrote it three
years ago I pulled it up a few days ago
it's just compiled some runs I have a
JavaScript version of the same thing
can't even install it fantasies so that
has lots of value to me like things are
stable and it's just things keep working
they don't stop working for No
at all so community is very good there's
a very interesting library called
closure spec which would require a whole
talk of its own it allows you to do
declarative data validations and you can
use it both in your application data and
on your code because your code is data
right so you could use it in place of
react prop types for validating props to
your components and you can even use it
like as a light typing mechanism you can
add it to your function arguments for
turn values and so on and so forth very
very cool data script there's a
full-featured relational database you
can run in your client-side applications
it has a query engine it's amazing I've
worked with it multiple times so I'm
just throwing these things out and
expecting you guys to go home and google
it core I think it's a library again for
asynchronous programming including
script which uses macros a lot which
kind of alters how the code is being
executed it's hard to describe very
quick list I'm just gonna leave it for
you guys to google it's cool so summary
I don't have much of a summary it's just
that this stuff is cool I hope that you
think it looks cool as well and want to
check it out like I mentioned I work for
Google Market and we're looking for
people to work with us so if you want to
work with me on cool stuff like this you
should talk to me and yeah that was it
thank you for your time
[Applause]